ses frères cet équilibre et c'est
savoureux pour la troisième année
consécutive la cuisine méditerranéenne
est en tête des recommandations d'un
panel d'experts américain sur la gestion
du poids normal c'est le régime allemand
est le plus étudié et réputé le plus
efficace au monde et cette diète la
réduit et les évènements
cardiovasculaires c'est les accidents
cérébrovasculaires les infarctus 900
spectaculaire chez des gens a évidemment
à risque de faire sous type d'accident
alors c'est beaucoup de l'huile d'olive
beaucoup de légumes frais puis c'est
dans la simplicité d'un que que la
meilleure nutrition réside en deuxième
position on retrouve un régime pour
réduire l'hypertension artérielle
puis un autre qui misent sur le
végétarisme à temps partiel le
flexitarisme en fait c'est un peu le
guide alimentaire canadien c'est manger
moins de viande sans l'éliminer faire la
place aux légumineuses au gré entier aux
noix aux grains donc aux aliments
végétaux et s'éteint un régime qu'on
peut suivre vraiment dans notre vie de
tous les jours le panel a également
sélectionné les meilleurs régimes pour
maigrir le régime végétalien arrivent ex
aequo avec un autre qui mise sur les
allemands faible en calories mais c'est
encore l'éternel weight watchers qui
domine malgré ses faiblesses weight
watchers et vous et du poids donc tant
que vous y allez savoir que vous faites
ce qu'on vous dit vous allez perdre du
poids mais dès que vous avez arrêté
votre poids va revenir parce que vous a
pas été éduqué faudrait vraiment moi une
façon de manger qu'on puisse soutenir à
long terme donc si on est toujours d'un
réduction de calories ou de restreindre
sur les aliments on a du mal à mes nerfs
salle on a également recensé les super
diet amaigrissante le site un classement
qui est contesté perdre du poids
rapidement
oui c'est très très possible de perdre
du poids rapidement mais à quel prix au
prix de quelle frustration et de se
remettre à manger encore plus quand on
va être conscient on va lancer la
serviette
en fait pour les experts comme pour le
commun des mortels la clé tient en
quelques mots moi c'était un peu
équilibré un peu de tout faveur du
plaisir la salle chez bamboo fun avec un
sac de chips une fois de temps en temps
ça fait du bien donc en gros d'un radio
canada montréal